[Music]
the Obamas have decorated the White
House with 54 Christmas trees 54 yeah
it's all part of their for the last time
we're not Muslim campaign get it through
your freaking heads
that's called overcompensating 54 trees
great news it's official Prince William
and Kate Middleton are expecting yeah
they don't know whether it's gonna be a
boy or a girl but they do know it's not
gonna work a day in its life kids on
easy street I couldn't believe this this
morning the Vatican announced that the
Pope is on Twitter that's true
Pope's on Twitter Pope's only been on
Twitter for about 15 hours he's already
called Chris Brown a douchebag
[Applause]
[Music]
he's done he puts it under his hat
that's where he keeps his iPhone yeah
put in there and put the hat back on and
then he goes around on the popemobile my
gay groups are apparently angry at
former President Clinton because he
hasn't come out in favor of gay marriage
yeah
Korver Clinton said he'd be willing to
have two lesbians come by and try to
convince him these are all true what I'm
telling you of course they are in its
first ever report that just came out be
Mars rover says it has found a number of
chemicals in Martian soil but none of
them are capable of sustaining life
whoever they are the basic ingredients
used to make a Doritos locos taco
[Applause]
hope keeps one of those under his hat -
tweeted on my chuckle what's your Pope
what is he Italian I don't know Italian
he's German oh he's German why don't you
do I'm making the pizza pipe oh I don't
know he's probably trying to fit in yeah
you got you got out of my trap this time
hey this is interesting speaking of the
internet it's the 20th anniversary of
the sending of the first text message
and that message was Merry Christmas
not cool it's also the 20th anniversary
of the first reply which was are you
horny
[Applause]
well didn't write down
Lindsay Lohan said she does not need
rehab because she says she has no
problem with alcohol
however Lindsay did admit that her car
is a total drunk it's been her car yeah
this whole time I've had a couple of
those better you've had cars with
drinking fries yep according to new
research that just came out
most women are happy with the size of
their man's penis the the study was
conducted with their man still in the
room
[Applause]
[Laughter]
eighty six-year-old Hugh Hefner 86 year
old who Heppner is engaged to a 26 year
old playmate they are getting married on
New Year's Eve
friends say that Hef's fiance is busy
planning the wedding while Hef is busy
remaining alive and I got to mention
this last thing I'll mention over the
weekend the nominations for the annual
porn Awards came out yeah I don't want
to sound bitter but who do you have to
blow to get one of those
like
[Applause]